مساء الخير في تطور خطير يجري في العالم
يعني ب علينا نحنا نكون مدركين لاهميه
شديده تاثير علينا الان وفي مستقبلنا في
العالم العربي هذا التطور بايجاز شديد
يتمثل في فكره فتور الحماس في العالم او
في كثير من دول العالم لفكره الديمقراطيه
الليبراليه يعني ايه الديمقراطيه
الليبراليه الديمقراطيه
بس الوحدها معناه ان تطرح الانتخابات يعني
الحكم الاغلبيه واللي جيب اصوات اكثر يفوز
انما الديمقراطيه الليبراليه اللي هي احنا
مفتونين بيها و شايفينها مثال يعني شبه
الكمال اللي هي فيها حكم القانون واحترام
الحريات العامه واحترام حقوق الانسان
واللي فيها فصل بالسلطات واستقلالها بعضها
عن بعض اللي فيها دور قوي اه مؤسسات
المجتمع المدني و للاعلام والصحافه
كل ده تقدر تسميه الديمقراطيه الليبراليه
اذا كان معنا مش واضح اللي هو نموذج
الولايات المتحده
هل هو نموذج بريطانيا نموذج فرنسا نموذج
المانيا اللي هي الديمقراطيات اللي احنا
كلنا كنا بنحلم بيها ونتمنى النبوي
امشي على خطاها هذا النموذج يتراجع فيه
دراسه ا تعاملت في الجماعه السويد في 2017
دراسه ضخمه وتوصل الباحثون فيها الى انه
في اربعه وعشرين دوله حول العالم عدد سكان
هم اثنين ونص مليار يعني تقريبا ثلث سكان
العالم ب تتراجع فيها الممارسات
والاعراف الديمقراطيه بشكل غير بعض هذه
الدول كان حديث العهد الديمقراطيه في
روسيا مثلا في فنزويلا البرازيل انما في
دول ثانيه كانت يعني عندها تقليد غربيه
اقدم زي الهند
ومن بين الاربعه وعشرين دوله دول صدق او
لا تصدق الولايات المتحده الامريكيه نفسها
تحت في
في في مساله تراجع تراجع الديمقراطيه
محتاجه امثله يعني هو فيها محطات مهمه
تقدر توصل وضحت النظر في فكره او وجهه
النظر اللي بتقول انه الديمقراطيات
بالتراجع لو رجعنا ال واحده من اهم هذه
المحطات تمت في مارس الفين وثمانيه عشر
وهذا ال في هذا الشهر اعلن حزب الشعب
الصيني او البرلمان الصيني عن انهاء
الماده المقيده في الدستور الصيني لفترات
الرئاسه واصبح
اللي كان مقيد ل واللي كان المطلوب يعني
او متوقع انه يقدم فترتين او ثلاثه على
الاكثر
اصبح الان يستطيع ان يصل في السلطه الى ما
شاء الله
البعض من المراقبين اعتبروا انه هذا الحدث
او هذا التطور يعني ببساطه شديده جدا
نهايه فكره ايمانه
الديمقراطيه الغربيه على خيال او على شعوب
العالم
لاقامه الصين اصبحت هي القطب الثاني في
العالم واصبح يتكلموا بالبهار عن التجربه
الصينيه يكون ان الصين تعمله المساله لا
تعني فقط انه الصين تخلت بشكل او باخر عن
فكره نموذج الديمقراطيه الغربيه
ولكن ده معناه ان في دول كثيره سوف تحذو
حذوها فيه نظريه في عالم استاذ علوم
سياسيه ومؤرخ اسمه كانت موجوده
لنظريه بتتكلم على فرصه
اللي هو القصر الملكي في فرنسا في القرن
السابق هذا ال
كلمه افاق تعبير كده مثلا يقول لك البطرك
يعني
البرصا
من وجهه نظر او نظريه خلصتها
يعني انه لما بيكون فيه نظام سياسي ناجح
في دوله قويه
الدول الاخرى كثيره بتحاول تقلده تمشي على
خطا وبين دي امثله كثيره الدكتور او
جهود على نظريته
والامثله مثلا انه في القرن ال السبعطاشر
لويس السادس لويس الرابع عشر قدر يعمل
نموذج مبهر للملكيه من قصف اللي هو
اللي عمل عليه دكتور كلمه نظريه دول كثيره
بثلاثه الترتيب او النظام البلاط الملكي
في فرنسا الدوليه المانيا وروسيا ودول
اخرى كبيره ومهمه
السياسي بيتكلموا اللغه الفرنسيه او
الملابس الفرنسيه يعني ابتهاجا او تقليدا
اول عم بتقليد هذا النموذج الناس صدر كتاب
مهم جدا كل الناس اللي مهتمين بالعلوم
السياسيه بعرف
اسم اه ان ترى او نهايه التاريخ
نهايه التاريخ والرجل الاخير
فيلسوف مهم اسمه فرانسيس فوكوياما هو
امريكي من اصل ياباني الخلاصه اللي
بيقولوا التاريخ انتهى خلاص ما عاد فيه
صراع في الافكار انتصرت الابد فكره
الديمقراطيه
الليبراليه النموذج الغربي للحكم هو ده
نموذج الامثل والنموذج الغربي ان اللي حصل
في بعض الحرب البارده انه مجلس الاتحاد
السوفيتي يحضر كمان افكاره خسرت للابد
واصبح فكره فقط هي فكره الديمقراطيه
الليبراليه الغربيه
الواقع الان ان بعد اقل من ثلاثين سنه
العالم باعتراف على فكره الديمقراطيه
الغربيه
وبالمره احب اشير لحضراتكم في كتاب مهم
جدا الكتاب ده اسمه
اساس
اثنين من الباحثين المحترمين في جامعه
هارفرد واحد اسمه
ودانات الاثنين الاساتذه من جامعه هارفرد
محقين كتاب وعملوا الكتاب اللي واللي
حضرتكم عليه كيف تموت الديمقراطيات
بيقولوا بيعبروا فيه على اه خلاصه الكتاب
انه بيعبروا فيها لا هم من تراجع
الديمقراطيات حتى في الغرب
ونصبوا الاربع مؤشرات خطر لما اي حاكم
بيعملها معناها معناه ان هذا الحاكم هو
يعني اقول مستبد او مشروع حاكم مستبد خطير
على الديمقراطيه حتى لو كانت الدوله
مشهوره ان احد قلاع الديمقراطيه في الحرب
العالميه الاولى عدم الالتزام او التزام
ضعيف بالقواعد الديمقراطيه
يعني القوانين الديمقراطيه مش مهتم ممكن
يتجاوز في هنا فهناك انه اه اه انكار
الشرعيه الخصوم
الخصومه بتعتبر انه هما مش مهم ودينا
واخوانه او يجب ملاحقتهم يجب التثقيف منهم
قد الطرف او التسامح في عمليات العنف
خصوصا ضد خصومه والاعلام الربعه الرغبه او
الاستعداد او عدم الممانعه في كبح الحريات
المدنيه او وسائل الاعلام الاربعه اللي
لما تتوافر في حاكم من وجهه نظر
جبله المؤلفين اللي كتبوا كتاب كيف تموت
الديمقراطيات يبقى معنا يعني هذا الحكم
مستعد طبعا غنيه عن البيان الكلام ده كلام
يعني حاجات بسيطه جدا
الحاجات بيتم في بلدنا بس انا اتكلم على
قد ما قرات ديمقراطيه الكبيره او المستقره
لما هو بيقول كده يعني او او او او يمكن
انه ببساطه تدرك انه الكلام دا لا ينطبق
في الولايات المتحده على سبيل المسلمين
طبق باستثناء واحد بس ال او اريكسن اللي
كان فيه احد هذه الصفات على مدار سنه على
مدار مائه سنه لم ينطبق الاعلى حاكم واحد
وهو دونالد اللي من وجهه نظر الباحثين
والمهتمين بفكره الديمقراطيه الغربيه
بيحاول القوى الديمقراطيه الغربيه بطرق
كثيره في الم عاداته او تصفيه او يعني
انكار الشرعيه على خصوم ومحاولاته تربطه
بالسجن اللي كلينتون والهجوم السافر
الشديد جدا على الحزب الديمقراطي وتشجيعه
بشكل او باخر على مطارده ال
المتظاهرين ضد الدرجه النقل من هو مستعد
ان يدفع ال يعني تكلفه
والملاحقه القضائيه لاي شخص يعتدي عليهم
يعني الامثله كثيره على التجاوب محاولته
او باتهام المباشره وزاره العدل الامريكيه
والضغوط اللي بيعملها على القضاه المؤشرات
تقول ان الولايات المتحده اصبحت اقل كثيرا
من
مما كانت كدوله ديمقراطيه ال اكثر من كده
انه
في اغسطس الفين وسبعه عشر في استطلاع
نشرته الواشنطن بوست ثمان وخمسين في
المائه من الامريكان اللي هما يريدوا
الحزب الجمهوري قالوا نحن لا نمانع في
تاجيل الانتخابات الرئاسيه في الفين
وعشرين انتخابات الفين وعشرين اذا كان
باعتقد الرئيس طالباني يكون لصالح المجتمع
الامريكي وان وخلصنا يعني اه في يعني انت
هايدي فرصه ان اللي صوت في الانتخابات
القادمه يكون امريكا مستحقه للتصويت وليس
اي مهاجرين يعني اه غير مركز في وجود
امثله كثيره المساله مش بس على طلب الكلام
ده موجود في دول اخرى كثيره زي مثلا دول
شرق اوروبا والمقر ابرز مثال على
تراجع الديمقراطيات بعد هذه الدوله كانت
متعطشه لنموذج الغربي باتت تشهد تراجعا
كبيرا عن النموذج مكمن الخطوره في تراجع
في
العالم الغربي عن الحريات الديمقراطيه
ما دام مؤشر معناه انه العدوى بتنتقل
معناها انه الدول اللي كانت بالاساس بتسعى
هذا اقل حماسا وخصوصا انه فيه قزي الصين
مثلا اصبح الان يعني غير متحمس لفكره
الديمقراطيه وهو نموذج ناجح في ايه اللي
يمنع انه حتى الرئيس مثلا ال الرئيس
الروسي بوتين يفكر بدل ما كان بيحاول
يتحايل على الديمقراطيه بانه هو ياخذ
فترتين وبعدين يجدوا حل ل اللي هو
اه اه اه ي يدخل هو رئيس وزراء رئيس
الجمهوريه ثم يعود عشان ياخذ فترتين وهكذا
كل ما نعمل غير الدستور
خصوصا بان المساله انه في بلدان كثيره
تتحمل الى فكره يعني
بدعم شعبي الى فكره من الديمقراطيه دي مش
مهمه
البرازيل على سبيل المثال قبل من فوز
الرئيس اليمين المتطرف الحالي اللي فات
في ال في شهر يناير
ليه لانه في استطلاع كان بيقول في
البرازيل ان اربعين في المائه من
البرازيليين البرازيل اللي كانوا بالدين
جدا من الفساد والجريمه لا يمانع جدا اذا
كان فيه انقلاب عسكري
والخلاص من الحكام او السياسيين الفساد
ونفس المزاج ده موجود في دول اخرى في
الفلبين
انا اذا حضرتكم المدرب فنزويلا
تايلاند
الانتقام فيها انقلاب عسكري على حكومه
ديمقراطيه وحتى هذه اللحظه موجودين في
السلطه بايدن اي انتخابات
كل ده على بعض معناه ان هناك
يتزايد رفض فكره الديمقراطيه الغربيه
السبب ايه
صعبه يعني الظاهره تحليلها انما الدكتور
مثلا عليه الدين هلال المفكر السياسى
المصرى المحترم اللي نظر لطيفه جدا وهو
شايف انه نتيجه وجود انه حنا بنعيش في
فتره انتقاليه وال نظام عالمي اه بيدها
دعا الى النظام العالمي بيتشكل وتكلمت مع
حضرتكم على حاجه زي كده في احدى الحلقات
عن افهم العالم فيه عشرين دقيقه
يقول احد مؤشراتها عمليه الانتقال او احد
فيه عمليه الانتقال هو وجود حاله من عدم
اليقين ومن عدم الرؤيه الناس عندها حاله
شك شك في كل قيم النظام العالمي اللي ب
يتداعى واللي كانت واحده من العولمه اللي
كانت احد من الراسماليه السوق اللي كانت
واحده من سمعته الليبراليه او الديمقراطيه
الليبراليه قد يكون هذا التفسير مقبول وقد
يكون هناك عوامل اخرى من المشاكل
الاقتصاديه مشاكل المهاجرين التطورات
التكنولوجيه العامله على الناس عن طريق
الفيس بوك وتمكين الفرد اللي قوي جدا جدا
ولكن بشكل غير منضبط قصه تستحق منا حلقه
اخرى
الاخيره اللي عاوزه اقول لحضراتكم اذا كان
الدول الغربيه بدات تتراجع عن هذا المفهوم
سيحصل بالمناسبه كمان في المانيا وفرنسا
مؤخرا الى حد ما من خلال صعود طيارات لا
تؤمن بفكره الديمقراطيه الليبراليه
كيف سوف يكون الحال في بلداننا العربيه
من المؤكد ان هذا سوف ينعكس بشكل سافر على
بلدنا وفي دول كثيره بعدما كان
اذا غيرها او تنقص على عقبيها في ممارسات
والتزامات اتجاه
فكره الديمقراطيه الليبراليه بصفه عامه مش
ان تجد اي حركه انها تراجع عن هذه الجهود
او هذه الالتزامات اشكركم والى لقاء اخر
ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]